salut aujourd'hui on est dimanche et
donc c'est le jour des explications une
fois par semaine j'ai invente un tour et
je vous l'apprends pour que vous
puissiez bluffé à votre tour vos amis
votre famille votre entourage cette
vidéo se passe donc en deux temps dans
un premier temps je vous fais le tour à
voula directement à travers l'écran et
dans un deuxième temps je vous explique
comment ça marche
regardez bien la vidéo jusqu'au bout à
la fin des explications je vous donner
deux trois détails qui sont importants
pour ce tour je fais péter la playlist
je vais vous faire voir une partie de ma
playlist à moi personnel des titres à
moi et vous allez en choisir un dans
votre tête dans votre esprit a et un
seul que vous allez fredonner dans votre
tête ou ou à voix haute d'ailleurs vous
pouvez vous faire un gif
moi je vous ai promis que je chanterai
plus donc je ne chanterai pas quoi qu'il
arrive y'a pas de problème dit chapeau
si vous avez nirvana avec taux d isola
sinsemilia avec pourquoi pas stromae
avec tous les mêmes metallica avec tous
forte ou abba avec je sais pas le
prononcer salle je parle pas suer de
voir les amis un lightning golf johnny
avec donne moi ma chance
eminem avec take me more frérot de la
vega avec je l'entends m avec c'est pour
elle et michael jackson avec not afraid
on dit titre parmi ces dit-il vous en
sélectionnant dans votre esprit vous
commencez à le fredonner à le chanter
même si vous connaissez pas très très
bien les paroles au moins l'air un petit
peu qui vous revient je vous laisse
quelques secondes quand je claque des
doigts faut que votre choix soit fait
quoi qu'il arrive c'est bon continuer de
fredonner un petit peu l'air dans votre
tête essayer de voir le chanteur devant
vous j'ai l'impression que c'est un
chanteur dont on avait parlé dans la
chaîne pour une des astuces du mercredi
alors je vais je vais chercher dedans
franchement vous fredonnez très très
bien dans votre esprit et je pense que
c'est un trop va vous parler
je coupe sinon je vais avoir des
problèmes de droits d'auteurs sur la
chaîne fait ce que oui je le sais vous
aviez choisi straumann et pourquoi j'en
sui 6 urbain parce que c'est moi qui ai
créé ça ce matin donc forcément
est ce que est ce que je vous le dit
d'ailleurs parce que je voulais explique
évidemment c'est parti pour la partie
explications dans la liste y avait dix
choix possibles avec dix groupes très
connus ou du chanteur très connu il ya
des plus actuels il ya des plus anciens
des français des américains même des
suédois davet de tout et pourtant vous
êtes allé sur stromae quand je vous ai
un petit peu speed et parce que parce
que parce que parce que parce que
c'était le seul que vous connaissiez
vous connaissiez tous les artistes
oui mais vous connaissiez pas les
chansons parce qu'elle n'existe pas je
les ai juste inventé ce matin juste
avant de faire la vidéo reprendront dans
l'or parce que la 5e va vous faire
marrer
il y avait nirvana avec taux d is all
sinsemilia avec pourquoi pas j'essaie à
chaque fois trouver quand même des noms
cohérent stromae tous les mêmes donc ça
c'est bon metallica tout forte ou abba
avec l'as tu n'aimes golf alors golf ça
veut vraiment dire étages en suédois
mais c'est surtout que là tu m'aimes
golfe si vous l'écrivez à l'envers ça
fait mentale blog oui ça m'a mise
et alors je cherchais un truc qui
faisait suédois en fait johnny donne moi
ma chance pour elle on a fait tellement
que ça passe et eminem techni mort
frérot de las vegas je l'entends je le
vois bien sortir un type qui s'appelle
comme ça mc pour elle c'est sûr un jour
il sortirait une chanson comme ça aussi
et michael jackson c'était le risque
avec notre poule est parce que les vrais
fans de michael jackson savent que ça
n'existe pas vous pouvez faire ce tour à
quelqu'un pour ça dans la description je
vous mettre un petit lien qui doit vous
permettre de télécharger la playlist et
pour le réaliser vous présenter la
playlist à une personne voulu décès dans
les mains vous lui demandez de choisir
un titre qu'elle est capable de chanter
dans sa tête de fredonner même si elle
connaît pas très bien les paroles au
moins que l'air lui reviennent vous lui
laissez quelques secondes vous récupérez
la liste la peine de lui laisser
éternellement parce que peut voir la
supercherie si elle est fan de l'un des
groupes genre de nirvana michael jackson
ou de john ici c'est votre père et comme
révélation je propose soit de faire
comme vous me voyez faire dans les
vidéos avec un bloc note et puis un
crayon ou alors ça peut être ça peut
être assez marrant vous pouvez mettre la
main sur la tête de la personne et faire
semblant que percevoir des choses aient
commencé comme ça maintenant à faire
je me dis que je chanterai plus et ben
je le redis je ne chanterai plus voilà
vous pouvez donc commencé à fredonner la
chanson comme si vous perceviez un petit
peu de ça peut-être à votre bras votre
esprit et je pense que la personne sera
d'autant plus bluffé que vous le fassiez
comme sa précision ultime en important
comprenez bien que si par le plus grand
des hasards ça n'a pas marché sur vous
par la vidéo les tours que je vous
explique c'est pour les refaire à
d'autres personnes donc en live en temps
réel c'est bien normal que parfois par
vidéo ça ne marche pas vous pouvez
mettre pause vous pouvez chercher sur
internet en même temps vous n'avez pas
forcément la même concentration je peux
pas gérer les personnes indépendamment
une à une
ne vous attardez pas à ça si jamais par
malheur ça n'a pas marché si ça marche
et vous pouvez me le dire dans les
commentaires je les vis tous surtout
tester le vous pouvez même le faire dès
aujourd'hui parce que là il a besoin de
trop trop répété en plus je pense que
vous allez vous éclater avec ça et si
vous aussi vous le pensez si la vidéo
elle vous a plu vous pouvez me faire
savoir en laissant ou est-ce que je n'ai
ni d'ailleurs pouce en l'air et j'ai
changé de côté merci à vous tous d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo si jamais vous êtes
un nouveau sur la chaîne n'hésitez pas
vous pouvez penser à vous abonner ça ça
fait bien plaisir
et sinon rendez vous demain à 17h pour
prochain mentale vlog ciao